I think if I had to summarize my
worldview I would say there are a lot of
terrible injustice ha's out there some
of them are currently and voguish Lee
the subject of all kinds of arguments
and protests but there are many out
there that people just aren't aware of
and it's my job to try to find in
justices or areas of life and power
black holes which are not subject to the
rule of law and the rule of morality in
the rule of philosophy and try to
subject them to legal constraints let me
give you a contemporary example which is
very very controversial so simply
observing what's going on in the Middle
East in Israel and Palestine in Iraq and
Afghanistan one clearly sees a new
paradigm of asymmetrical warfare going
on terrorists hide behind civilians a
merge with civilians operate out of
civilian population centers and use
those areas to attack the civilians of
the democracies they're opposed to Hamas
fires rockets into downtown stay road or
Hezbollah fires rockets into Haifa or
Iraqi terrorists fire rockets and
American soldiers or in Afghanistan it's
going to spread all over the world and
the democracy has two choices either not
to respond or to respond and if they
respond they will inevitably kill
civilians on the other side that's part
of the goal of the terrorists they want
the democracies to kill civilians even
if it's their own civilians because that
creates a terrible world impression
against them which is part of the reason
why Israel has been subject to so much
criticism as the United States has been
we need a new jurisprudence to deal with
that phenomenon the old jurisprudence
doesn't work the old jurisprudence
simply said you're either a civilian or
combatant if you're wearing a funny hat
with a
insignia and a uniform you're a
combatant if not you're a civilian that
dichotomy doesn't work with terrorism so
I've had to construct what I call a
continuum of civilian ality which ranks
people along a line obviously babies and
old people and others who have no
influence on the aspect of terrorism
they're totally civilians people who
allow their houses to be used to store
weapons people who allow their
themselves the user shields are closer
on a continuum to civilian ality two
combatants it has to be made a war crime
to use civilians as shields and to fire
rockets from behind the civilians and
there has to be a rule of
proportionality that allows democracy to
respond even if inevitably it's going to
risk the lives of some civilians to save
the lives of other civilians we right
now don't have a jurisprudence for that
we don't have a jurisprudence for
pre-emptive attack against a nuclear
power threatening to attack others not
imminently but in a year or so I'm not
suggesting that it should be permitted
I'm suggesting that we needed
jurisprudence the article 50 and 51 of
UN Charter doesn't deal with that it
says only that a country can respond to
an armed attack with an armed attack but
if you're waiting to have a chemical
biological and nuclear weapon directed
at your civilians nobody reasonably can
be expected to wait and so we need a
jurisprudence to fill that black hole
and my life work is to try to find
construct create at least the beginning
of a jurisprudence so that nothing is
outside of the rule of law that's my
goal nothing under the radar screen
nothing left to discretion everything we
do subject to the rule of law that
probably created the greatest
controversy in my academic life I looked
around and I said we're torturing people
we use torture I think that's wrong I'm
personally opposed to torture but we're
using it so i said if we're going to use
it we need a jurisprudence of torture oh
my god a jurisprudence of torture how
can you say that you're a monster your
Torquemada now
I'm trying to stop torture and the way
to stop torture is to cabinet to say all
right if you think you have to use
moderate forms of physical pressure in
the extraordinary case of a ticking bomb
terrorist who knows where a nuclear bomb
is in the city of New York all right
create an exception for that but cabinet
limited indicate and people say no no no
we don't want that we'd rather have the
President or the Vice President or some
people on the ground do it on their own
just don't ask don't tell a wink and a
nod that's not my way my way is always
to have the rule of law govern
everything that we do whether it be
torture whether it be execution whether
it be race-based affirmative action
whether it be censorship on the internet
things that I oppose I still want to
have a jurisprudence I oppose the death
penalty but can imagine having a death
penalty without a jurisprudence to
constrain it or take a problem of an
airplane flying toward a building with
lots of people in it and we're pretty
sure the airplane has been hijacked but
we're not positive somebody has to make
a decision whether to shoot down that
airplane and kill the 300 people on it
who might not be crashing it who might
be crashing in we can't just leave that
to the person on the ground we have to
have an advanced jurisprudence to figure
out when we can shoot that airplane down
and when we can everything needs a
jurisprudence that's my mantra and if
there's ever been a contribution that
I've made it's the contribution of
creating a rule of law creating a
jurisprudence for everything we do no
exceptions